hey guys happy tech Tuesday so today I'm
gonna tell you about this little project
and when you complete this project
challenge it's really simple so bear
with me tweet me your photo proof of
completion and I will tweet you guys
back as a thank you
so I'm so excited to be partnering with
Microsoft on their youth spark challenge
for change as most of you guys know I
absolutely love technology I love
everything about it and I love getting
other people to love it just as much as
I do one of the best things about
technology is no matter what your cause
is technology has the power to help you
do more good by partnering with
Microsoft they want to support your
ideas for changing the world I know a
lot of you guys have these crazy ideas
or some of you might just have a simple
small idea and no matter what it is you
guys have the chance to win funding to
make it a reality and so excited about
this project because when I was younger
I had all of these crazy ideas
I still have crazy ideas of things that
we can do to change the world one of you
guys and have this opportunity and I
will be there on the sidelines cheering
you on so all you have to do to enter
it's pretty simple you just go to the
youth spark hub page or you could enter
the challenge and some contact details
and answer a few questions about your
idea upload a photo and that's it and if
you guys want to tweet make sure you
guys capture that last little page sure
to send your tweets to at iJustine and
use the hashtag youth spark so I can
find your tweets the best part there'll
be ten winners from around the world who
will win a life-changing trip to
Nicaragua to learn more about creating
social change you'll also win $2,500 to
make your ID a reality and some really
fun Microsoft goodies hopefully I can
get around to tweeting all of you guys
the last time we did a little project
like this it took me a while and I
promise you I will try my best to get to
all of you and if I don't see your tweet
the first time please feel free to send
another one
happy tech Tuesday stay tuned for an
actual tech review next Tuesday I can't
believe today's actually Tuesday see you
guys later